-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
President Biden spoke yesterday
with Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky
for nearly an hour.
Zelensky secured
$500 million in aid
and Biden somehow ended up
with a reverse mortgage.
[ Laughter ]
Intelligence officials
reportedly believe that
Russian President Vladimir Putin
has only recently learned how
poorly the invasion of Ukraine
has been going and is angry
with his military advisers.
And you can tell he's upset
because now the table
is even longer.
[ Laughter ]
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said yesterday
that Republican
Congressman Madison Cawthorn
admitted that claims
that his fellow lawmakers
had done cocaine and invited him
to orgies were exaggerated
and added that Cawthorn
told him he,
"Doesn't know what cocaine is."
Guys.
[ Laughter ]
You got to keep
your denials believable.
It's okay if you know
what cocaine is.
I mean, look at this guy.
[ Laughter ]
He knows what cocaine is.
Maybe he never did any.
But every guy
who looks like that
hangs out with eight other guys
who look exactly like that,
and one of them
always has cocaine.
"Oh, hold on.
Yeah, no,
it's in my puffy vest."
[ Laughter ]
McCarthy also added that
Cawthorn has lost his trust,
which is tough because once
you lose Kevin McCarthy's trust,
you almost immediately
get it back.
[ Laughter ]
Organizers of Sunday
night's Academy Awards
said in a statement yesterday
that Will Smith refused to leave
the Oscars
after slapping Chris Rock
and added that they,
"recognize we could have handled
the situation differently,"
like maybe hiring
younger security guards.
[ Laughter ]
"You got to go!"
"Got to go.
You got to go.
I don't think he's going to go."
[ Laughter ]
"Whoa!"
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams spoke
at an event this week
about the status of
the coronavirus pandemic
and said, "Everyone
who moved to Florida,
get your butts back
to New York City."
Everybody?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let's not get carried away.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is April Fool's Day.
April Fool's.
It's actually today,
because my show airs at
a ungodly hour of the morning.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to a new study,
men who eat
excessive amounts of meat
increase the risk
of becoming infertile.
So get ready for that
to be an excuse.
"Baby, we don't need condoms,
I just had ribs."
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.